ينضم الينا من واشنطن كاميرا مستشار
المبعوث الاميركي السابق الى السودان
ومسؤول شؤون افريقيا السابق في البيت
الابيض سيد كاميرون هل الجهود الامريكيه
تقف عند حدود اداره الازمه ام تتعداها
للبلوغ او للوصول الى الاسباب الحقيقيه
التي ادت الى هذه المواجهات
واو
اعتقد ان واشنطن الان تركز على حمايه
الرعايه الامريكان وتساعده في عمليه
اجلائهم من السودان ولكن ايضا
قامت بدور دبلوماسي وثيق في البلد وهذا
يعود الى اتفاقيه السلام الشامل مع دوله
جنوب السودان فبالتالي واشنطن لدي مصلحه
طويله المدى في السودان ونحن ارتكبنا بعض
الاخطاء هذا واضح وهذه الاداره قامت بذلك
في
منهجها لدعمها للحكم المدني لذلك سنرى ما
الذي سيقومون به اذا ما استطاعوا ان ينهوا
هذا الصراع بالنسبه لمسار النقاشات
الدبلوماسيه لا اعتقد انه يمكن ان نعود
الى النظام والعمليه التي كانت قائمه قبل
العنف حيث
الجنرالان كان لديه المقاعد في السلطه
والان قد خسر شرعيتهما ان كان لهما اصلا
شرعيه
ولذلك لوقت طويل السودان
كان يدار باناس مسلحين واذا ما سمحنا لهذا
الوضع بالاستمرار فسوف نكون نحن اصلا جزءا
من المشكله سيد كاملا ما تقييمكم للجهود
الامريكيه منذ اندلاع المواجهات هل ترى ان
الجهود الامريكيه على قدر الحدث
مره اخرى اعتقد ان واشنطن
تتحلى بالامل ولكن لا اعتقد ان الطرفين
يعطينا سببا للامل فهما
يدري كان بانه اذا ما استطاعاه فرض الضغوط
من خلال الدبلوماسيه لتحقيق ما يريدان
وكما انهارت المحادثات السياسيه وواشنطن
كانت تعتقد باننا نحرز نجاحا لذلك لا نصدق
والجنرالين عندما يقولان بانهما سيتوصلان
الى هدنه كما الجنرال البرهان قال انه ليس
لديه
نيه بالاطاحه بحكومه حمدوق بينما كانت هذه
هي نيته بالضبط وحميتي والبرهان قال انهما
مهتمان بحكومه مدنيه وانهما يجهزان لذلك
في الوقت نفسه كان يجهزان للحرب ضد بعضهم
البعض اذا لا اعتقد انه يمكن ان نستمر
بقبول ما يقول له يقوله لنا الجنر الان
وان نستمر بالعمل بناء على ذلك فاذا ما
قامت واشنطن بذلك فهي خطا طيب سمعنا
اصواتا داخل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
تلوح باستخدام العقوبات متى ممكن ان
تستخدم الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
العقوبه وهل يمكن اساسا ان تلجا الى ذلك
المتحده تناقش موضوع العقوبات الان واعتقد
ان واشنطن الان متردده بنسبه لوضع
العقوبات لوقت طويل في السودان العقوبات
كانت في جوهر السياسات الامريكيه بالعوده
الى التسعينيات عندما اعلن ان السودان
دوله راعيه للارهاب من خلال الحرب ايضا
بين الشمال والجنوب
الوضع الصعب والحرب في دارفور اذا فمن
خلال تاريخنا الثنائي واشنطن تود ان تبتعد
عن العقوبات المشكله هي ان الجنر الحميطي
والجنرال الجنرال برهان يتجاوبان فقط مع
القوه وما لم تكن واجنه مستعده للتعامل
معهما بقوه
فانهما لن يهتم بالجهود الدبلوماسيه من
واشنطن والسبيل الوحيد الذي يجعله من
يتجاوبان هو اذا ما تم استهدافهما مباشره
بالعقوبات اذا ما ايضا استهداف لاخوتهم
وشقائهم وشركاتهم
بالعقوبات اخر مره الولايات المتحده فرضت
عقوبات على السودان كان عام 2007 اذا مرت
خمسه عشر عاما منذ ذلك وحان الوقت لاعاده
النظر في فرض عقوبات على السودان وان تكون
مستهدفه لاولاك الناس الذين يقوضون الحيز
الديمقراطي في البلاد واستخدام العقوبات
ليس لمعاقبه السودان ولكن لمعاقبه الناس
الذين يقومون بتدمير السودان شكرا لك سيد
كاميرا هاتسن مستشار المبعوث الامريكي
السابق الى السودان ومسؤول شؤون افريقيا
السابق في البيت الابيض